I'm Robert Scoble and I've been doing
online communities since about 1984 and
I have a story a historical story I grew
up here in the valley about a mile from
Apple computer and I belonged to a one
of the Apple user groups that that was
going and we had a friend a friend of
the club one of the one of the people on
in the club had a garage and we turned
it into a BBS we had six computers with
six 2400 baud modems that made these
horrible sounds when somebody called in
you know and it was incredible people
could call in to these modems from
around the world and trade a few files
which were very you know nothing like
Facebook today right just a few text
files see we would get email from you
know Korea or Europe or something like
that and it would be very a synchronous
we would have to wait a couple days for
somebody to dial back in to get our
email over to the other half of the
world right because they would have to
connect their BBS's that were going on
around the world and join in and call in
to our modems and trade those text files
and now we have the you know we have
YouTube where I can post hi-def video I
mean I was at loic's conference in Paris
and I was uploading video in ten minutes
that was 1080p high def video and
putting it out on the Internet and
people around the world we're watching
it and interacting with it in live time
this really it really incredible age
were in compared to the 1980s when
things moved a lot slower than they do
today
but actually that's why I wanted to pull
up Google Buzz so you could just watch a
little bit I have something I'm
following 8600 people here let me just
refresh this and make sure it's going
and this world is moving very very
quickly in it so if you're trying to
build a brand in this world and get
noticed if you're a musician or a CEO or
a business or a social project trying to
help Haiti or what not you're gonna have
to compete with this world that just
keeps moving at this speed and keep in
mind I'm only seeing a very very tiny
slice of this world right there's 400
million people on Facebook and
I'm only seeing 80 600 people here on
this screen so and you can sort of get a
sense of it just keeps moving all day
all night you know you can get on at
2:00 in the morning and see LOI you know
twittering with his friends and but it
just keeps moving like this all day long
hey Scoville and you guys can do this
too um and and so I I just want to put
that up there because how do you get a
business going and this kind of always
on always streaming constantly
increasing speed world right I art with
four people or maybe 40 I CQ is a good
example this they released to 40 people
on November 1st 1996 how many people
here have heard of ICQ yeah so 40 people
november 1st 1996 I got on it because
Chris Pirillo friend of mine told me you
know you gotta get on this cool new
thing right and I joined around December
15th which was six weeks later I was the
65,000 360 first person on on the system
right so in six weeks
they went from 40 people to 65,000
people and that was in 96
so today everything has compressed how
does that happen when I quit Microsoft
so I worked at Microsoft for three years
and was a blogger and a videographer
they're going around doing interviews
with all sorts of people there when I
quit Microsoft
I told 15 people at a conference smaller
than this room and I told them to keep
their mouths shut until Tuesday right
this was a Saturday because I what I
hadn't told my boss that I was actually
quit I mean I was in discussions with
him and he knew it was coming but I
hadn't actually made the call and said
I'm quitting and of course it leaked but
it leaked from a guy I didn't even know
so what it wasn't an a-lister it wasn't
Mike Arrington or Arianna Huffington or
anybody like that it was a guy I didn't
even know right and I know thousands of
people I study this world every day
Wagner Hedstrom
Microsoft PR teams was tracking how many
media hits it got and they said within
three days 15 million people saw that I
had quit Microsoft from those 15
conversations I didn't do a press
release I didn't call up the Wall Street
Journal I didn't try to build a you know
a PR thing I just told 15 people and
they found the story interesting enough
to tell their friends about it and
leaked from the guy who I didn't even
know and the story started doubling so
it's leaked 7 p.m. and every eight
minutes it doubled so it went from one
block to two blogs to four blocks and
when I hit about 8 blogs I called my
boss and I said I'm quitting because I I
knew within 15 or 20 minutes he was
going to see it on his screens and then
he would be even more pissed than he
would have been if I had not called him
likely I caught him before he saw it but
yeah it just kept doubling every few
minutes just like ICQ kept doubling
every few hours in the early days and
then later it was doubling every 17 days
fun story if you if one of my favorite
questions is would you rather have
$100,000 today or would you rather have
a penny that doubles every day for a
month to me an innovation is a penny
that doubles every day or doubles every
N days or doubles every eight hours the
problem is most people can't recognize
that doubling penny until it hits about
20 doubles so on day 20 your you have
about a thousand dollars in your pocket
so if you know you're gonna die on day
21 take the hundred grand right all the
money all the money is due to
compounding interest at the end of the
month and you get five and a half or ten
million dollars at the end of the month
I'll do two compounding in interest
right which you guys all know when when
I talked with Bill Gates and said go buy
this company called Flickr or go by
Skype this was before Skype led to eBay
I said these companies are doubling
Penny's you gotta own them you know this
is what you want to go in a car and he
the answer Steven Sinofsky who now runs
Windows wrote me an email back about
this big and it had the words business
value repeated 13 times
it was too early in the doubling stage
for them to understand that it was
doubling penny it was day ten right
there was a few dollars and they didn't
understand that these things were gonna
continue doubling until they hit
hundreds of millions of people and
become businesses that are worth
billions of dollars so that's my lesson
is I I study how people work how ideas
spread from person to person I you know
if you come to my Twitter page you'll
see a list of tech company executives or
innovators or tech companies let's pick
on tech company executives and see what
they're writing right now and these are
executives that are everyone from a
start-up executive to an executive at
Microsoft and you'll see what they wrote
in real time and a lot of them I can
tell you something about them like Sokka
is an investor in Twitter you know
Jeremy Toman launched five companies at
CES and there's one best of CES I don't
know four times I think and so I start
learning and by reading these people and
meeting them face to face I start
learning about who they are and what
kinds of things they want to pass along
to their friends right so I know Jeremy
tomans totally into gadgets he helped
launch bug labs which is a really
innovative company and he helped launch
Slingbox right in which many of you have
and so I know he wants to hear about
gadgets or see innovative companies in
the gadget space or there's a certain
kind of thing you know
compare that to MC Hammer he wants to
hear a different kind of innovation he
wants to hear about both music and
entrepreneur innovation and maybe he has
some of the same interests that jeremy
does but i start looking at how to
create us to pass along a story when
when I first sold Seagate so Seagate was
one of my sponsors for a couple years I
told I went in there and I said let's
not talk about Twitter or Facebook or
whatever is going on I want to hear what
is your story how do you want to change
your story to the world and that started
a much better conversation about what to
do don't my first advice is don't get
caught up in these tools because they're
just tools get caught up in what's the
story you want to tell you know do you
want to raise a million dollars for
Haiti well how do you do that you know
who are the people that you want to
touch and get in touch with right and
then you need to study you know start
with one of them like pyramid or witch
Loic knows right he started even he has
a lot of money so if you're trying to
raise money go where the money is right
and maybe you know Loic knows him
because loic's following him on Twitter
right so study who's following him and
study who's going along and build the
goat take Loic out to lunch learn
something about Loic first 2 hours you
know and and buy him a nice bottle of
wine because he likes good wine and then
he might introduce you to peer which
might which will be a much stronger
relationship than if you just try to
email peer out of blue and he doesn't
know who you are this is how I got most
of my interviews at Microsoft I would
start with one guy that I knew
interviewed him and I would ask him well
who else should I interview oh there's
another guy over in researched you
should interview him well can you
introduce me because if I just calling
he's gonna go you're a jerk you know I'm
not think about trying to do what I did
so I add my soft I interviewed 600
employees company-wide right
I interviewed everybody from Bill Gates
down to the janitor think about going
into General Motors and trying to do
that as a new employee not as an
executive because one thing about
executives they're too busy to do
disruptive stuff like this right it has
to be so many six levels down that
doesn't have the trust of everybody well
how do you get trust how do you build
these networks inside a company how do
you ask for an interview
well if you go into some guy's office at
General Motors or dizzy or any real
company they're gonna start becoming
very just very defensive because they
know the
camera can hurt me right one of the
tricks I used was I used $250 camera
instead of buying a real expensive big
camera because it helps you relax and
when you're relaxed you're more willing
to tell me stuff right but imagine
you're trying to do that at chellah
motor it's trying to change the image of
a global brand you know you're not gonna
get the front door because you don't
have the trust and if you do have the
trust if you're an executive you don't
have the time you're too busy just
chasing the business you're like Steven
Sinofsky with billions of dollars of
business in front of you and hundreds
that were thousands of employees that
you have to manage and you're too busy
to try something new and disruptive so
how do you how do you go deep into the
company and change your company's
culture
I talked with Tony say who runs a post
I'm sure you all know this did you know
that when you get hired there you're
forced to tweet why wouldn't anybody
have an idea of the principle behind
that he he forces you to tweet for a
couple reasons one he wants everybody
from the janitor to the CEO to know that
they are a brand ambassador that they
are responsible for the way we view that
brand we he knows that brand that we all
change opinions of brands at 2:00 in the
morning on a Saturday when I need help
with something when I have a bad
experience or a good experience I need
some help or I need some my ideas hey I
need some shoes for for a party I'm
going to on Tuesday and I I don't know
what to get so you start writing you
know help me Zappa you know and if you
get an answer back that builds a brand
there's somebody listening at 2:00 in
the morning on Saturday who's passionate
about what they do and is willing to
engage with me
well that that employee could be a
janitor could be somebody eight levels
down from the Tony could be Tony himself
Tony answers my my tweets all the time
right he knows that this new world is we
need to be empowered to take care of
people and that brands and movements
happen
at weird times Loic is gonna tell you
about his post he wrote last night one
of his tips was you got to be on 24
hours a day you got to figure out how to
get your company to be on 24 hours a day
you know
Rackspace has 300 people on Twitter the
company I work for and we do that
exactly for that reason so that if
you're down or if there's a problem or
if you get a new job and oh my god I got
a build you know a website for the
National Football League and I have
three weeks to do it you get some help
you know you get somebody to talk to and
you have a public face you know we all
know how many people know a new media
Jim who is Jim long he was a camera guy
in the White House with NBC he's on
Twitter
all right let's let's actually pull his
tweets up here yeah
to me he is NBC to me right he's a
camera guy and I and I if I see
something happening in the White House
if if Obama announces something I can
ask him what's going on you know with
what's your opinion and I've met him
right so he's credible to me I met him
face to face and he will answer back you
can see he's answering people back you
know if I had problems with my comcast
line I go to Comcast cares you know i
twittered him and I said hey I'm having
problems uploading my videos in the
videos after I got home from Luke's
conference he had a gigabit line and my
videos were going up in 10 minutes and
the same video would take an hour and 10
minutes at home and I said how how can I
is there any way to increase my speed
and he he actually while I typed with
him he checked and he said yeah you you
can't get high-speed lines in Half Moon
Bay
but we cannot upgrade your router so
reboot your router and you get another
half a half a megabyte upload speed and
it made a little bit of a difference now
that takes 15 minutes to upload that
same video but that that made me feel
better about this brand that was a
faceless
mega-corporation that I would have to
sit on hold for an hour and a half just
to get to a human being like this
you know Ford Scott Monty you know yeah
how many people have heard of Scott
mommy before today a few right this guy
is changing how we think of Ford a
Francine Hardaway one of my friends is
driving a Ford Focus just because of
this guy
you know and how he's personalized a
corporation and how he's communicating a
brand message that's very interesting
and now Ford is winning Innovation
Awards why partly because of Scott and
his social media team that he's working
with because it's getting you to believe
that Ford is a different kind of company
than it used to be right and I could
keep going on and on but I want to get
these other two guys on on stage and get
some questions but this gives you a
taste of what's going on out here and
and the the tools that it lets somebody
change the global meme in my head of
what Ford is and this guy might even be
working out of his house in his pajamas
I don't know you know he has like here's
a DSL line like I do where a a comcast
line it's a interesting world we're
living in some other one last thing that
I want to leave you with because now
that I'm studying tens of thousands of
people I'm studying 17,000 people coming
to me in Twitter and 8,000 people and
good in G Google Buzz and I watched this
on a big screen so I have two big
screens that I can see a lot more than I
can hear I'm fine that we the people in
this industry who have studied this and
built online networks around the world
we're craving intimacy now and that gets
back down to the floor people we're
craving less of this kind of experience
what yeah okay
we're craving less of this kind of
experience and more of an intimate
dinner conversation with 4p
pull and turn that around you find the
right for people you can change the
world